now
well you may think we have a lot of golf
courses in las vegas but maybe not
enough golf ranges and there's a new one
that's being built right on the strip
ron futrell is there joining us live
this morning to tell us all about it
it's not only just for hitting golf
balls but it's also a lot of these cool
spaces too for having just a whole lot
of fun right ron
oh yeah sherry this is going to be a fun
place to come out have some golf good
golf and enjoy some time with friends
here atomic range here the
groundbreaking taking place later today
here it's going to be open let's see
sometime before the end of next year
john volbrecht is with us now from um
flight golf tell us okay this is where
now we're outside we're going golfing
okay this is outside tell us what you're
going to picture what we're going to be
seeing here a year and a half from now
yeah it might be hard to imagine
standing here right now but in about 14
months you'll have a four-story 99 000
square foot building sitting here with
beautiful views of the mountains
downtown it's going to i think really
change this whole look and feel of this
part of the strip yeah we're just on the
north side of the stratosphere is where
we're at so you can picture i said
stratosphere the strat okay that's old
school the strat is where we're at and
you see a beautiful area where this is
going to be i've seen some of the
renderings and it looks just marvelous
what you're going to be building out
here and this is by the way for you guys
flight golf your first venture in vegas
isn't it absolutely yes it's our first
one here and it's going to be the
biggest facility we've built so
you know go big or go home i guess okay
here we go golf shot go big or go home
we're going to hit some shots here we
got the balls out here ready to go i was
thinking of going now tell me what you
think of this shot um the world market
center is about a mile and a half down
here i've got a five iron probably not
enough club actually hit the world
market one of these new cobra clubs you
could probably
reach it yeah but i don't know about
that one okay this one might not make it
off okay and then over to the pool how
about that rain i'm hitting off the
crane over to the pool you are going
where what shot trying to match it try
to oh you try to match it okay here we
go rob's going to hold the mic here and
do play by play for us rob thank you all
right okay what do you think ready give
us a countdown all right no talking in
the back swing three
two one
all right
we blew it up
look at that girl
the exploding golf ball
i think i hit the top of the ball i
think i
did that a little wait ron was that an
exploding golf ball
it's a girl
market center
but
no fun times out here looking forward to
when this is finally done here a lot of
construction happening here on the north
end of the strip but thank you for
joining us here bright and early in the
morning john thank you it's been a
pleasure okay look forward to atomic
range grand opening today it'll be open
here by the end of next year have some
fun get some tubs
no i was wanted i wanted to see it
happen oh no